no and have his babies by any means if
I'm on the boat with a poster I'm
getting her out the way and then I'm
leaving I'm not getting them
we see real event what is your cash out
I want to know commitment
can we talk about okay
I have a genuine question about the red
I don't need y'all's money man it's on
fire so y'all just sub for me seriously
I don't want nobody's money I'm just
trying to bring contacts this is not me
just curly things
I have a genuine question based on
ignorance because I don't know about the
red pill movement that much okay so this
is coming from
oh I want to learn more about what this
movement is about okay what is your
stance on commitment on a man's
perspective because I feel as if again
this is me just from the very little
that I have seen I have noticed that in
the red pill movement men do not seem
want to commit to women again now this
is the one video that I saw it was one
of your guests I don't remember his name
okay one of the videos that I saw was
this dude saying that a woman does not
have high value a woman is does not have
High Valley and a woman's Prime is only
between 18 to 25 and it's okay to
recycle women as you get older and so a
woman again this is the video that I saw
it the the Woman's Worth only comes from
being deemed a Queen by a king and uh
she only gets her worth based of the
last name that they get so again in my
in my opinion in my opinion it seems as
if this video this man is telling men
to not commit there's no reason to
commit to men if they're just going to
be jumping from young woman to young
young woman so again I want to know I
want to open up the floor can you
explain to me if the red pill movement
is encouraging or discouraging
commitment it's discouraging
but I think purple pill is encouraging
you need to get that's why I'm here you
need to get you a blue pill or a purple
pill guy I don't get a red pill again I
think that it's kind of both right so
red pill is like knowing your reality
right so like obviously us we're
aspiring to be multi-millionaires right
a lot of men are comfortable within
their realities right so they're doing
their nine to five they come home they
satisfy their wife right so if that's
your reality right don't allow your your
wife to take advantage of you right
for us we're going to continue to do our
thing right so we're committed to the
woman that we're with right but also as
we build ourself obviously we're not
going to you know remain stagnant if
that answers your questions
um to answer your question I would say
that the red pill
um discourages men from getting married
because men get a bad deal today I'll be
oh
they get a contract that women are paid
to leave and they're they're men value
Purity and youth and the average age of
first marriage in the US is like 28 29
that's not young anymore and that's not
pure how many bodies you got by 28 29
and so it's like they're right there
they're accumulating all of the risk and
what do they get out of it they don't
get a virgin bride anymore so it's like
they're they're looking at the costs and
the benefits and they're just saying you
know what we're not really getting the
things that we want anymore so [ __ ] it
and I'm sorry
they say Purity and youth yeah I want to
date children I mean otherwise all the
wives in my life
their husbands don't even come home to
all the house
I feel like husbands don't even come
home to a warm cooked meal like they're
eating leftovers from the night before
but like so like you said I feel like
men are realizing that they're getting
like the [ __ ] end of the stick and it's
just kind of like
they kind of it's not that they never
knew their words but I feel like men are
actually stepping into like a phase
where they're like I know what I bring
to the table and it's like
you know maybe she's
not bringing why'd you do that no he was
threatening me
you know your career is over with go
ahead sadly I'm unemployed I lost my job
so don't worry about it careers
in your opinion oh you're interesting no
this is a fact that I ended her career
tonight right no no whatever floats your
boat or whatever 34 29 29. and how old
are you 26. so can we all agree that you
know as a woman your your fertility rate
you know lowers as you get older right
oh my God right so the order you get the
less likely you are to obtain a man most
likely because a man is looking for some
a woman that can give him kids right
that makes sense right so that's on what
they are looking for there's other guys
out there that don't want kids so that's
that's what I mean that's what I meant
when I was doing the percentages before
and you said where is this going right
we can't go off of the minority right as
a majority most men look at the woman oh
me and this woman compatible what's our
kid going to look like where are we
going to go going forward right so
moving forward from that right that's
what that clip meant right 18 to 26 or
whatever that age range means we're not
saying women after 26 are worthless what
they're saying is 18 to 26 is that
optimal range you find a woman that has
less bodies is still fertile and you
know you can build a life at a young age
rather than trying to you know adopt
have a woman like yourself no not to
come at you or anything you already have
your core values you've been through
your men you don't want to tell us your
body count so you're saying that you
want to groom women you want to groom
them at a young age the the definition
impregnate them and not commit to them
the definition the definition of
grooming is somebody that's under 18
that you're trying to you know you can
groom someone over it you cannot groom
an adult yes you can how do you groom an
adult
excuses excuses
you can't manipulate someone at this
table right now I can manipulate
something I always want to be okay
I would love to try a very hard time
you wanted to be a victim with a guy who
slept with twice
whatever whatever makes you happy
whatever you need to say get it out so I
I don't have to say so I'm a rumor if I
go after an adult that is younger than
me
okay Maryland have you seen the
documentary with Marilyn Manson and I
can't remember Rachel Evan wood I have
not she was groomed by Marilyn Manson
she was old enough to know what was
happening but she fell into the the
mystery and the velor the the Allure of
him it's not the one in California but
they like murdered the family no there's
no murders in this I thought that was
Manson no she's talking about the guy
that was just super golf yes the guy the
guy that's supposed to why he sucked his
dick with his mouth or whatever so why
is it right why is it that in 2022 women
are allowed to he took a pair he took
ribs out of himself so
why is it in 2022 that we allow grown
women you know to say that they've been
manipulated in all of this I saw this
earlier when he made a comment and
you're like oh so we're allowed to do
this right to you right you're like like
oh we're saying that this is okay the r
word right yeah oh you're like how do
you know we drink right as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible